[Music]
welcome home honey
do you read now what is this it's
classified
oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
they call it bad behavior
hey why are you here I got this
situation when I need your help I need
bad friends
cause I'm the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
oh shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
if these babies go off
it'll be world war three
to choose this life over friends
over family
It's Time to Get Loud
next slide baby
[Music]
of imitation distance constitutes the
reservation
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
is that the biggest one you've got oh
it's way bigger than that
Our Lives
are the sum of our choices
[Music]
we cannot escape the past
Ethan this mission of yours
is not a costume
dearly
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing war is coming
it's been a long time for him
you've no idea the power represents
knows your story and How It Ends
listen to me the world's coming after
you
his fate is written
shall we write yours too if anything
happens to them there's no place that I
won't go to kill you that is written
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]
in 213 BC
Archimedes go to the dial
that could change the course of history
with this we will have our Victory it's
not yours you stole it then you stole it
[Music]
back
we gotta get there first I can't do that
you want to stop for a little lie down
here
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
rated PG-13 only in theaters June 30th
tickets on sale now
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't
nine seconds
that's what I'll give you to decide your
fate
[Music]
what did you do back home
I'm retired
[Music]
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real people
and I'm starting to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
foreign
[Music]
that's the median nerve but I'm
compressed
that's a level three you don't want it
to go to a level four
seem like a man who understands violence
you can't take that from me
I can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily do you kill him
[Music]
nine seconds
well I look like a killer
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
Jonas we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
Jonas
we've got company
it's the biggest snake I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator
everybody might get to the station
three massive exit who knows what else
can escape the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
you don't want to know
[Applause]
we've never seen this before they hunted
it back
everybody
we can relax this place is Meg proof
when Jonas was always afraid of this but
I was also thinking
foreign
[Music]
you finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
so Out Of Reach you always land on your
feet bro you're hymen
but do not open it you went in to get us
jobs and all you brought back was a
hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked
the hell is that
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me
[Applause]
oh man
okay it's gonna be okay
[Applause]
re-entry systems ready
things that you want
what is going on
it's called this character it's some
kind of world destroying a weapon it's
designed to protect the toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it does it
I I think I cut a bus in half
mascara chose you
it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe's sensual gift and you have
to figure out what you're going to do
with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
[Music]
toys
it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
[Applause]
all right
well it looks like this is home for the
night
goddamn win
Clarence
local officials have declared a
Statewide emergency as these
unprecedented storms continue to rain
[Music]
sure got a Bus full of prisoners heading
our way got caught in the storm we need
a place to hunker down until it's safe I
want you on your best behavior while
we're here let's get a few things
straight you're in my house now I will
not hesitate to shoot you if I have to
if y'all don't think this is a crew and
unusual right here
just tell me how I alligator got in your
damn police station the storm brought
him in could be infested with him by now
if you want to survive the night we're
gonna have to find a way to get along
keep an eye on him that's a Bonafide cop
killer right there
we're all gonna get eaten alive
[Music]
he got one shot Sheriff
I hear the taste like chicken
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello hello
[Music]
is this an Avengers test
where's Captain Rambo
[Music]
what the hell yeah
hi we're looking for Kamala Khan
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
hi where's our daughter wherever you
were
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
oh look we're really sorry Splinter some
other guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to tuck him out of it yeah you
rented us out don't use that word that
way I mean it's 20 25 already dead
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we take out
Superfly and then everyone will think
we're cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
huh I can't believe there are other
mutants you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dunk
my son Michelangelo you have heart
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage it's not a
problem
welcome ladies I'm Jasper McDaniel beer
pilot this is awesome
this is cool
bags arrive no clothes this bag looks
just like mine we have to call Jasper
there is something off about him I say
we do one just one you make me Drop Like
Love
where's our little Bloodhound Daisy
we're coming for
you we have to do something Simon timer
we have to call the cops good morning
bring the product and I'll bring your
friend if we call anyone she's dead we
need to handle this wow we're going to
get a call in a minute
you're gonna answer the phone read
exactly what I wrote
we have what you want but we also have a
very particular set of skills skills
that make us a nightmare for people like
you let our friend go now but if you
don't we will find you and we will kill
you
[Music]
what next
oh cats real she's crazy
after all she's been through she's
trying to make up for what happened to
her you mean how West her brainwashed
her and made her come after us no one's
blaming Jill for that
no one
doctor and Taylor yes we need him in
custody ASAP I checked the DNA we got
from a bite wound on an orca carcass it
had a strain of t-virus in it you're
kidding I found the connection between
the folks that were infected they all
visited Alcatraz recently
well Dr Taylor
it's time we debuted our
creation
they turn fast and without being bitten
I'm Rebecca what do you want me to tell
them someone accessed the dod server
they managed to steal data on Leon Jill
Chris and Claire you think this might
have something to do with the operon now
most likely
I'm going to use my virus too clean the
Slate Dylan
you're nothing more than pause
I can't be good
[Music]
excuse me
it's all yours
we're at the final stage now that there
is no justice well it's over now
[Music]
lights you up let's do it all of us
definitely going on vacation after this
hi I love you thank you passing you into
Mr Wayne no please don't stop
so you're saying you could travel back
in time
hey Bruce I can fix things I can save
people I can save my mom
I can save your parents
you can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school Google was good
oh
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die
again
it's not Clark my name is Cara I will
help you
interesting group lots of help
wait he's Batman
you want to get nuts let's get nuts
for an unguarded territory
we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
you have fancy friends
yeah it was an Uber oh exec
it's a peaceful place in the sky
no
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
[Music]
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
for as long as AI is a threat we
never stop hunting mountains no this is
a fight for our very existence
whatever's in there they're sure worried
about someone getting in
yeah we're getting out
[Music]
come back to you
we're the same we can't go to heaven
because you're not good
[Music]
and I'm not a person
take the weapon yeah it's a key
what do you want to wait the track
[Music]
we are this discs to winning the war
execute her or we go extinct
[Music]
they're coming to get me
foreign
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
what does my mentor do besides bring me
roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in
that Arena
you start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games
[Music]
two
enjoy the show
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
[Music]
there's a natural goodness built into us
all
across that line into evil
or not
hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
[Music]
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance
everything is about winning
the monsters
it's the things we love most
Try Us
foreign
who do you think the best driver is
probably Rory I would dust him in a lap
yeah all you do is play video games with
some crazy dreams of racing cars Doug
you're the one that told us always do
something we love you know what racing
cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
get a chance to compete in professional
racing dude this is real
[Applause]
I'm sorry you really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
it's not gonna work the guys who race
are Elite athletes but I won't stop now
your kids are scrawny little gamer kids
well that's why you coming come on let's
go
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
puked on my lawn there's no turning back
now when you're in a race the cockpit is
going to be 140 degrees Fahrenheit
the g-forces will be twice when an
astronaut experiences upon liftoff I
can't see anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game
[Music]
this whole thing is insane but on the
Couchsurfing nerds that you sent me he
is the best one he made it
welcome to Team Nissan
major leagues the other drivers are
going to hate you
[Music]
'll probably start of the game it's
called racing
if you miss the line in the game you
reset you miss it on the track
you could die
I know this track
a thousand times
that's what I'm talking about
but I won't stop now
these guys put their lives online
every single day
we sleep good at night because these
guys deal with the ugly
[Music]
how are we gonna get out of here
one tastes for sure
it'll come out the same way you went in
see how it stays two suspects present
possession of God
looking at life for killing a cop so we
need your connect we got a tip from a
confidential informant about a stash we
got suspicious you didn't notify him on
the warrant
just one of those things
watch yourself
remember that money house I told you all
about
I need your help
you get a million bucks do you hear what
you're asking me to do
this without you
it's informative
yeah I don't think I could do this bro
you better do it
foreign
[Music]
you figure they were cops here
I've been having nightmares what if
somebody finds out
it's Tommy taking money on the side
never
got a dead cop a Euro partner and a
widow this investigation is over my gut
is right on this summer all you got is
conjecture
[Music]
you're about an inch away from getting
bounced out of the iabs our jobs protect
the community uphold the law sometimes
you got to do a small wrong
for being right
[Music]
I got to stop doing this
foreign
[Music]
laughs
I'm going off the grid disappearance
where is Hank we have to find him
preparation doc we got a huge problem
with the new product
we're launching tomorrow gentlemen get
to work execution amen minions Battle
Stations the trail gentlemen what can
Arch do for you conspiracy this is a
threat against our very Foundation we
must protect our Collective from this
clear combination
negotiation I shall take it from here
skedaddling you're gonna have to run
away what
tightness
stairs doc are you okay what the hell is
going on over there this is a setup you
can't possibly think I did this
we've been waiting all day for this
haven't you the veggie Brothers
radiant is the blood of the baboon heart
so that could have been a baby's head
now do you get it
[Music]